ladies and gentlemen are you ready to
rock and all roll Harmonix has announced
that for 2015 it's headliner is the one
the only rock band for the new music
game will launch for Xbox one and
PlayStation 4 by the end of the year
developer Harmonix has revealed new
guitar drums and microphone peripherals
are coming by way of a partnership with
mud cats however in an effort to keep
the community united rock band 4 will
not support keyboard or pro controllers
as for the rock band peripherals already
released on xbox 360 and playstation 3
harmonics product manager daniel Susman
said the team is working their asses off
to support those old controllers for
rock band 4 perhaps the more important
question for gamers is will my existing
rock band dlc carry forward well that's
the plan according to Sussman he said
we've been working with Sony and
Microsoft to support legacy entitlements
so that dlc you bought on the ps3 will
carry forward to the ps4 and the same
with the xbox 360 to the Xbox one
although it is unclear right now if
you'll be able to move DLC across
console families for example ps3 to xbox
one finally Susman said that rock band
sport will be the only new rock band
game released for the Xbox one and
PlayStation 4 he said we don't envision
a rock band five six seven or eight what
we would rather do is build on the rock
band for feature set through a very
deliberate content and title updates
that are developed in collaboration and
conversation with our community and what
with activision room is to be working on
a new guitar hero game it sounds like
the hills of 2015 are going to be alive
with the sound of people playing plastic
instruments for all the latest on rock
band make sure you keep your eyes on
gamespot
you